sau chế tháng của đàn rất trường tương sò ở lửa đếp trong cuộc bầu cử hạ viet.
Thủ tướng như bản xuân ấy ta cay chi đã quy định gửi tặng qua,
cho bà chăm người lắm nghĩ sĩ cùng đàn.
Món mọi quà chỉ giá khoảng 8 miền nghiên,
tương đường với một trong chi mẹ hai đồ lắm ý,
và được lợi trọng thung qua,
cất tà ló từ trung tâm thung mai,
chỉ vì đã bao gồm vận chuyển và thủy theo tụi tướng ta cay chi,
chỉ phía được chi trà từ cuối chiến chiếc của nhà ngờ đếp tại tình ra rà dọc bà đứng đầu,
không sự dụng năng sức nhà nước.
Bà tà cay chi dài tính mục đích là bài tổ sử chân trọng trên tháng,
của các nghỉ sĩ và hỗ trợ công việc là phát của họ.
Tuy nhiên, hành động này là tất cả giới tru ý,
vì gợi nhờ đến bởi cuối đây năm nay nghiên, không trao i ba.
Khi cụ thủ tướng vương vương yêu khi xin ra gặp khó khăn chính trị,
dởi đứa lập cạnh bà,
không việc gửi qua của thế làm giới lên trinh luật,
về mính bạc cính và chính nhận chính trị.
Đột tay trợ chính trình như bản châu phép đống góc thông qua đàn,